[Music]
in order to tell this tale of a
demon-possessed girl properly we will
need to start from the middle of Raiders
of the Lost Ark Indiana should be
finding the lost city of Tanis as we
speak Jesus Christ that's a lot of
people working on this project even if
it's government fund the lot and people
working on this project 1970s parkour
you see in movies it doesn't always have
to be a you'd better come take a look at
this cliche even though the kid doesn't
know exactly what they found at least
he's giving father Merrin all the
information he has I'm so pissed that
other movies don't do this I'm gonna add
ass in here even though this movie
doesn't deserve it hope you're happy
with yourself Hollywood holy is that max
von sydow guy has an age today since
Minority Report man this is for sure
going to ruin the Brady Bunch Hawaii
vacation look I know this movie is a
classic and that it's trying to
establish the origin of the evil that
came from this Iraqi archaeological site
but it also takes the movie goddamn
forever to set this up also we know
later that Merrin makes a trip back to
the States and somehow this amulet ends
up in a house being rented by a
Hollywood actress daddy has Jack to do
it but the movie isn't interested in
telling you how that happens Wow this
demon has the evil power to stop a clock
I guess it's just warming up its asshole
prankster muscles before it gets down to
the real possession business it's
important to stretch you don't want to
pull a hammy 70 King seconds of watching
Marin amble slowly out of town wait
where'd the sound of the falling rocks
come from that dudes literally just
standing there you know what place is
evil when it makes dogs fight each other
it's kinda like my neighbor Rick's house
gang Rick Wrenn looks like this demons
itching for an old-fashioned staring
contest and father no blinks just the
guy for the job
wow there's a weird and loud noise
coming from a very specific spot in the
Attic better go immediately check on
Reagan's room to see how she could
possibly pull this off Chris is acting
in a movie called crash course and it's
about to do a scene where they're about
to tear down a building at a college I
feel like once they film this scene and
only this scene the whole movie will be
done look I'm sure script rewrites onset
are pretty common but this seems like a
pretty important scene you're telling me
Chris had no idea what was happening
until today
shall we some on the right absolutely
nothing about what just happened in the
scene makes any sense to me first off is
what they just said that funny
become the spectators even hear this
conversation man for a movie that's so
critically lauded for being one of the
scariest of all time the sucker sure
does spend a lot of time on the B
through G plots and there's not a day in
my life that I don't feel like a fraud
jeez either Chris has some miracle ears
to overhear this conversation or the
clergy of this church have severe
problems modulating the volume of their
voices the director said let's have your
character type while eating an apple
it'll make you look like even more of an
asshole
I got an invitation I see Richard Nixon
has as big of a hard-on for Hollywood
actresses as Jack Kennedy poppin all all
the boy I'm a Catholic the problem is
this homeless guy had him an altar boy
but lost him with Catholic man the first
third of this movie could just be called
long tracking shots of people walking
because a basketball goal doing here if
you actually get the ball through the
hoop doesn't the ball go downstairs into
this place called the basement and if
you went after it wouldn't you likely be
killed by the swamp monster that lives
down there little known fact Georgetown
was the number one consumer of
basketballs in the 70s nobody knew why
until now no one will be seated during
the father Karras tree wraps his
mother's injured ankle portion of the
movie Jesus I feel like the actual
possession lasts like 12 minutes in this
mother so is the movie saying that out
of all the kids and all the houses in
the entire world
Pazuzu picked Reagan just because she
found a Ouija board it was all the way
in Iraq how did that make it to DC I can
like daddy well seems like this between
Chris and Reagan main seem long and
drawn-out they effectively show why
what's about to happen it's so
devastating most horror movies these
days don't give us this dynamic with
kids and their parents the kids start
seeing weird and draw a bunch of
disturbing pictures in school and we're
supposed to care because her kids ma'am
anyway I'm removing us in for this Chris
thinks she hears rats up in the attic so
the most obvious thing to do is to open
that corrupt so they can race down into
the living space it's honestly like
Chris has never house before also are we
to believe that was seriously captain
howdy Pazuzu up there and if so did it
take Chris opening the attic to let him
out - for the Reagan what are the rules
of this possession dammit earlier when
Chris told Carl there were rats up here
he told her this attic was clean now
maybe he was telling her it was clean as
in there are no rats but this attic is
far from clean you know what they say
demons cannot resist a pyrotechnic show
before a proper possessive but you see
notice no rats thanks a lot so are you
not the least bit concerned about what's
making all the noise up here now that
you've got confirmation there are no rat
you've got to focus your search on
raccoons and if it's not records and the
next step is ghosts or demons right a
full minute of this guy doing his flower
business just so we can see the Virgin
Mary's been vandalized oh that Pazuzu
such a prankster to the point that even
though he has a much more important
possession to get to he still makes time
for some childish jokes involving
grotesque who Haas and Lala's never
change Pazuzu I'm gonna take you out of
here mama
this goes on for some time oh yeah I
can't wait caris versus Pazuzu too I
have even pre-ordered on pay-per-view
Clarence Thomas damn Nazi is there any
good movie reason why the director of
crash course is berating the Swiss
Butler guy for being a Nazi if I went
around telling people the story of The
Exorcist would I leave this part in or
would I take it out and how long before
the cops arrest me for rotating my head
360 degrees in a public park this
alcoholic German a phobic character
unfortunately inspires the central
mannerisms of mr. Bean's yeah I don't
worry about my little dead daughter
that's directly upstairs and trying to
sleep or I should be down here doing
shots anyway
way to go Reagan before this Burke was
the party's biggest embarrassment did
Burke pay you to do this again dude I
know Chris is probably plied with
alcohol and whatever awesome pills they
used in the 70s but this is a slow-ass
reaction time to Reagan's weirdness it's
just like the doctor said it's nerds and
that's all what King dr. fear Reagan may
have a complicated psychiatric history
but we haven't seen any of that her
character so far she's been a
happy-go-lucky kid with a bright
attitude and a good relationship with
her mother get the out of here with this
sudden diagnosis man you put a quarter
into one of these things and you just
never know what to expect also couldn't
she you know get off the bed she said
this has happened before when she moved
into Chris's bed and she was clearly
able to leave that time haha we don't
take sin seriously at Georgetown do
clergy dream of allegorical public
transit so Reagan's possessed now right
but not all the way possessed this is
the period where they're trying to
prevent rejection before she gets fully
demonized the whole thing off the
Florida shaking the whole thing mrs.
McNeil the problem with your daughter is
not her bed it's her brain well I guess
you have a point I probably should
forget about that bed shaking thing
probably completely unrelated Jesus the
doctors smoke - it's like the
Exorcist was funded by Marlboro like
what was a clue into the fragile human
soul merely turned out to be a
successful lobbying attempt by the
tobacco industry there's nothing that a
vast displacement at all but this
asshole doctor still decided to go with
one of the most invasive tests to
confirm a baseless theory about a rare
disorder in a child with no relevant
medical history except some mild
psychiatric issues Jesus I'm convinced
the last five minutes of this movie was
just an excuse to show us the gory
details of brain imaging from the 70s it
seems too real man how come more movies
haven't been able to replicate demon
possession like this is it because this
movie spoiled it for the others anyway
this is hooked up enough to remove a sin
hey that's ours mine ethological states
can induce abnormal strength accelerated
motor performance and tell me doctor
when's the last time you saw a patient
yelling me and all that you just saw a
90-pound woman is your child pinned
under the wheel of a truck runs out even
if the wheels I have a foot up off the
ground pretty sure this is mom femi now
I know the temptation to leap to
psychiatry but any reasonable
psychiatrist would exhaust there's so
many possibilities first or maybe they
could lend their expertise as part of a
complete differential diagnosis instead
of these bozos continuing to spout off
about a temporal lobe injury that they
know isn't there look I'm not a doctor
and I'm sure medicine has progressed
over the last 45 years but this
yada-yada of the cause of Reagan's
pathology is such bull it's making me
feel like Pazuzu in myself keep any
drugs in your house no he's just asking
this now I think it's time we started
looking for a circuit and if he also
happens to be a priest all the better
hello damn steam is such an asshole and
he's apparently taken over all the major
utilities just so he can properly put
the whole family forex dead bye-bye
Berkey also sheesh man there are better
ways of getting out of babysitting tell
them you got jury duty er that your mom
is in a coma your pet snake accidentally
ate your other pet wombat anything he
must have been drunk he fell down from
the top of his steps right outside for
some reason he was railing against the
Third Reich and gurbles do a mom and her
son before he fell
I mean right who has the creative
wizardry to finish crash-course now is
this someone inside you wait is the
demon hypnotized too can that happen is
he sleeping going up for a smoke like
why can't they keep Reagan in this state
for a while until they figured out
what's happening why you and that's why
you never sit within crotchal reach of
your patience it really is the first
thing they teach you in psychiatry
school what do you know on the subject
to witchcraft one week into the
investigation of the death of Burke this
detective resorts to asking priests
about witchcraft which is Kam amazing
police work if you ask me and this is
all because they found his head turned
completely around which it was unusual
but still you got to witchcraft in one
thing weak his head turned completely
around didn't happen in the fall it's
possible I mean yeah all right isn't the
fact that the fall likely broke Burke's
neck and that his head was turned around
as a result much more likely an
explanation than witchcraft you think
that given the desecrater of the shame
maybe somebody crazy somebody with a spy
sure sure sure and Hollywood directors
who are in no way affiliated with the
church at all you see it's all falling
into place yeah I love to talk discuss
dude
if we find anything we can even call
them since that fits your line of work
right father we could form a club for
cinema a sort of cinema sins if you will
that's clever
this wasn't found at the scene if they
thought it was murdered then they surely
ran across this and yeah it's covered by
a patch of grass now but wouldn't a
patch of grass at the bottom of the
steps get searched
especially with all those cops at the
scene also what is this statue it's not
the one that mayor and found in Iraq but
yet somehow is also an evil harbinger of
death and if so why doesn't this effect
kinderman and make it very probable that
the deceased was killed and then pushed
on your daughter's window there was any
possibility that Burke was thrown from
Reagan's window why isn't this place
crawling with cops and when Chris drove
by the death scene was in a completely
different place
hey and even if this area is somehow the
back side of Chris's house why didn't
she react at all seeing that crazy scene
outside it doesn't make a lick of
goddamn sense he wouldn't have any
reason in the world except that he was
technically babysitting while Sharon
went out to get the meds right Jesus
Christ does anyone understand this plot
besides the possession parts yeah very
nice baby
well add these two people from a
mainstream movie in 1973 can reaffirm
their binary existence with the program
Hollywood Gees in one of the movies most
disturbing scenes where demon-possessed
Reagan is stabbing herself with a cross
I've just got to wonder how did she get
the cross back just as the detective
came to talk to her Chris put the cross
down on the end table surely you're not
telling me the hulking demon came down
and brought the cross back right well
apparently she learned the Queen's
English considering this accent also
let's go back to the scene for a second
to steamin who has thrown a man out the
window and down some steps managed to
supernaturally move this chair and close
the door
then made this dresser come tumbling
after Chris right after but then he let
her go sometimes this movie's abrupt
editing works in this case I demand
answers how did an exorcism well the
first thing I'd have to get him into a
time machine and get him back to the
16th century
oh Jesus these two have been doing their
walk and exposit for the last almost
three minutes and we're still dicking
around the point of this conversation
why'd Karis even agreed to meet Chris
here in the first place well I'll have a
subterfuge at all since we learned about
mental illness paranoia schizophrenia
all those things they taught me in
Harvard oh yes didn't I imagine I went
to Harvard
secondly the church before it approves
an exorcism conducts an investigation to
see if it's warranted that takes time
just a minute ago you said that the
church hasn't done an exorcism since the
16th century
now you're telling her the procedure for
how the church decides to do an exorcism
as if they do this all the time the
movie does say that the church doesn't
want to advertise this service and this
guy is losing his faith so he might not
care but how do you jump from exorcisms
haven't been done in forever - well if
you wanted one it takes a lot of work to
green-light it - would you like leave a
message Sherpa Zuzu's a dick and a demon
and all but does it know everything
about everyone
Karras hasn't even been tangentially
associated with this case so demon Regan
hasn't met him before and he even pricks
this motherfucker by asking about her
maiden name I'm just saying this is
creepy enough without the weird
specificity if that's true then you must
know my mother's maiden name what is it
what is it it's so much prettier in the
original Greek though damn our American
pronunciations dude
I know we got dirty from the pea soup
vomit but does Chris really need that
iron Karis is fucking sweater accidente
man this demon sure does know a lot
about stuff
he's like an encyclopedia satanica okay
seriously even if this is fake wouldn't
Pazuzu know what holy water is used for
the hell man
this causes captain howdy to ride in
pain and speak in that backward language
which ultimately exposes the truth about
the possession but it's not even real
holy water so again I say hello man oh
come on guys listening to a powerful
demon talk on a tape and the phone is
what's scary it's funny to me that in
the movie world phones or some
unexpectedly loud scary bull oh what's
wrong honey cheering didn't tell curious
what was going on until now even though
he came all the way out here you would
want to do the exorcism yourself man
that was easy
I mean Karis whipped with nothing but
his testimony and his uneducated opinion
didn't he just tell Chris that it was
nearly impossible to get approval
without hard evidence this escalated
quickly what about the Exorcist role
devil stays at Woodstock now what's he
doing there teaching I don't know but I
bet it involves some bitchin drugs
dan Billy freakin must have worn that
cross-dissolve button out for this movie
needlepoint needlepoint look I know
Chris is trying to distract herself and
everything but is there any probable
scenario in which she would be able to
concentrate on needlepoint during a king
exorcism wow this is just a simple
reading from what amounts to an exorcist
manual it's one of the most intense
scenes in movie history there are any
big showy moments just the confident
reading of one Max von Sydow damn for a
demon possessed a little girl she's got
excellent Lukey le carr rhetoric listen
if she's gonna be bedridden for a while
it is important to stretch as much as
possible Pazuzu can make an entire
building shake but apparently can't get
Regan out of fucking bed do however much
the scene has been parodied it's tensest
and i must remove a sin for how awesome
it is is she gonna die no not if I have
anything to die about it ah Jesus scare
me oh wait that was a doorbell
door bells aren't scary phones are scary
oh wow Pazuzu killed Merrin how you may
ask especially considering he's had the
upper hand this entire process jus says
movie I'm scary
this attempt at pounding a man's chest
to revive him is definitely the work of
a guy who went to Harvard Bellevue and
Johns Hopkins also now that he's dead I
think it's appropriate to ask what the
fuck was all that the beginning of the
movie introduced
just a father Merrin sure but how did he
end up taking his evil amulet statue
combo that he obviously knew was evil
all the way to the states what did he
get stolen tell me more about how all
the evils got in this house
dude there's been a lot of going on here
for several hours but just now the
detective shows up
damn this is gonna take a lot of
paperwork since the detective didn't see
Karras throw himself out the window how
do you explain this without also
including excerpts from occult books
from the library or do you just charge
Regan with murder look I understand this
is tragic but this just happened and DC
is a big King City you're telling me
everyone got here at a moment's notice
wait a minute how the hell did anybody
get thrown from that window directly
down those stairs if the window is to
the right of the stairwell it also looks
like a pretty long distance like it
would require a catapult to even get
close to it okay dumb little piece of
wood give you bad luck unless hitch in
the head anyway I don't think I want it
anymore
that's dumb you want it sure why not
it'll make a great souvenir nice I can
smell your are you sure well of course
I'm sure I'll tell you I said oh crap
everybody lies on your left
I've never met one priest who was
performed an exorcism that one yeah well
I need an old priest and a young priest
smooth what a lovely singing voice you
must have